he's got to he's got to be ready to move
ala Tempo and he's and he's thinking too
long two seconds one second three he's
gone
did he did he fly did he flag it's not
clear it's hard for me to tell is this
clock Frozen it says zero zero on my
board right now
and he says it I believe it says it on
the clock
and by the way this move Bishop F6 sets
up the threat Rook takes B4 check and
the Arbiter is about to intervene yes
this was a game lost by Gary on the
clock or likely to end in a draw how is
nepo doing because nepo was also still
uh let's say on the hunt he's still
playing but let's uh let's just finish
this one just to make sure that we're
not getting any other results by the way
my mediarov versus Anand has ended in a
draw as expected and that game uh Shaq
wait oh my goodness Gary lost on time no
mvl wins the game on Time
seals the deal oh my goodness hey
the aggressive pieces fishy getting
nervous she's stands right there we've
seen Vichy show some nerves what
happened uh oh what happened three
seconds two seconds one second gone it's
over that's it hey flagged what was that
I don't know what it was the game is
over guys yeah game is over Gary what
was that